today's show is sponsored by expressvpn
my savvy fans secure their internet
join them at expressvpn.com yang
i feel like being a child actor breaks
you know x percentage of folks
um you know let's call it
sixty percent or whatever the number is
it really does mess people up and i've
uh it it's i i'm not above saying like
it's probably messed me up to some
degree
i do my best to have it not mess me up
too much i've seen it mess other people
up
way worse um for a lot of reasons and
it's part of what is actually
makes me really concerned about the way
that online culture
is moving right now which is just and
look there's something really wonderful
about kind of
democratizing fame but
what it also does is it
it brings those kinds of struggles and
that kind of
addiction into khan at
everyone's life it worries me it makes
me feel like we should be worried
you know yeah like you have teenage kids
like you know having like their entire
high school class like following them
into their bedroom like you know on
their smartphone or whatever i mean like
you know
like that that's a very intense
experience that yeah
previously think of yourself differently
if
you are a performance and there's no
boundary there then like it you it's
it's easy to lose track of that
core relationship that you have with
yourself
[Music]
welcome back everyone to yank speaks
we're here we've got joseph gordon
levitt today which is extremely exciting
before that we've got some news of the
day andrew news of the day we need to
talk about
tick tock which you've joked about i
think you've said
tick tock is on instagram instagram is
too intellectual for you
yeah which which sounds like i'm poking
fun but i love tick-tock i've been
um endlessly amused by videos on
tick-tock i've been in videos
uh the creativity is awesome and immense
and if you don't use tik-tok it probably
means that you're old
because if you're a young person you are
all over it
it's very much the social media network
of the future
and when word came out that trump
was looking to ban it uh there's
immediately an anti-trump reaction to it
because he's an and like he's
doing it because the kids were screwing
with him in his rally on tick-tock and
sarah cooper was mocking him and like
the rest of it
but uh you know there there's a
legitimate case to be made that
tick tock having access to our kids data
is not a good idea
it's owned by a chinese company bite
dance that
has almost certainly some sort of
relationship
with the chinese there have been some
indications that
they are that tick tock is
appropriating folks data and
facebook instagram twitter have all been
banned in china essentially from the
get-go
and so there's a legitimate case that
chinese ownership of a social media
network that's used by
all of our young people is not a good
idea and
it looks like microsoft is going to buy
tick-tock
and then depending upon how your
feelings to me i tweeted that that's a
win
because if you're looking at a social
media network that has tens of millions
of users
you need a heavy duty player to come
take stewardship of this if it's going
to grow and function well and have
the right security in place and
everything else
and microsoft certainly has that heft
the danger in my mind
was that facebook or google was going to
wind up with tik tok which i did not
like
but microsoft is something have been
also ran
in social media they do own linkedin
which
you could consider a social media
network for professional purposes but
most people don't really think of
linkedin that way
you know you're not like going on and
sharing your kitchen videos on linkedin
or if you
uh are then you probably people yell at
you too if you get two persons and you
do that for a living
so it uh so i think the microsoft
acquisition of tick tock
is a positive resolution because
it assuages any of the data ownership
concerns
uh at least in so far as the chinese
government
is attached and then
it goes into the same levels of concerns
you have about
major tech companies owning our data but
at least
microsoft is not facebook just uh
gobbling up more and more of the social
media networks that exist
if anything facebook and
instagram should be separated and i
think at this point
congress is kicking itself in the head
or the ftc
for allowing that acquisition to take
place a while back
um because that that would have actually
led to a much more genuine competitive
landscape
in social media and andrew you've talked
about that a lot about the competitive
aspect of these companies
so if you don't know what tick-tock is
you're probably like me
only nine percent of the country the
united states actually uses it
but that number jumps to almost 50 49
when you talk about teenagers so the
kids are all doing it essentially and
adults have not even come close to
keeping up so my question for you is
facebook has been obliterating any sort
of competition to me
tick tock is the only realistic
competitor in the social media like up
and coming new competitor in the social
media space
is it right so it feels right to not
like quote unquote give this to facebook
but is it right that our federal
government's like here you go microsoft
you can be a player now like what
like what's the government's role in
that it feels like russia a little bit
where we're like oh here's a company for
you
you know um obviously that's extreme
example but what are your thoughts on
the government's role in
handing over the one new competitor in
this space
well again if you're looking at the
range of technology companies that could
afford the
let's call it 50 billion dollar
acquisition of tick tock
the list is not that long
and and you want to find a company that
is not a major player in consumer facing
social media and microsoft
again depending upon how you categorize
linkedin qualifies
right most people think of microsoft as
this boring stodgy
business software company and and so it
doesn't have the same problems
uh i don't dislike it because again the
the range of realistic acquires is
pretty
limited and like there weren't many
folks that could actually absorb a tick
tock and have it make any sense at all
yeah the other thing is for those
listening it is
there this is legal and there's
precedent on this like the the committee
on foreign investment
cfius is in their right to either block
mergers or encourage mergers or block
various acquisitions um so this isn't
while the left hates everything trump
does i don't think this i think i agree
with you i think
rational thought would say this is
probably the right move to make sure
that half of our
teenagers aren't being spied on by the
chinese government
and tick tock is going to continue to
exist uh and instagram just released
its tick tock clone to your point about
competition
reels uh you know so haven't tried it
yet
so in terms of consumers being able to
to make short form videos with fun music
and the rest of it i mean that that's
not going away i mean tick tock
you know if it changes hands like the
average teenager might not even know
what freaking happens
yeah so uh so i'll all will be well
ticktackers out there
appreciate you yeah you you know keep
using that creativity i enjoy tech talk
i mean it is i
like uh you know you can see why it's so
uh popular and growing so it's generally
hilarious
um i'm a fan too um
so i wanted to talk with this quickly
because
we're now we're recording this on
basically six days but by time you
listen it'll be well over a week
um since july ended which was when the
unemployed 600
expansion on employment um dried up if
you will and canceled and congress has
done
nothing and i'm pissed because
my thought is very simple and i would
love your thoughts andrew my thought is
very
it's simply that if congress can't help
us right now
like at this moment like when are they
ever going to help us
right like the world's burning
everything's on fire like please act
and they can't get their together
now is it hopeless like what are your
thoughts on
the congress in action and where we are
now
yeah it's a sign of just how
dysfunctional things have become
where to me it's pretty clear that
republicans wanted to drag this out to
the end of july because they thought
then democrats would cave
on whatever resolution they came to
because they thought that democrats
would not allow
benefits to expire and nancy pelosi and
the democrats decided not to go that
direction this time
and so now they're trying to bridge a
gap between a trillion dollars and three
and a half trillion dollars it
breaks my heart that families are going
to miss benefits for
let's call it two weeks because even if
a resolution
is hammered out right now like it's not
going to be like immediate disbursement
of
benefits to folks i do think we're going
to see continued unemployment benefits i
do think we're going to see
some kind of stimulus check to folks
again but it it's disgusting and
infuriating that our
leaders would be playing fast and loose
and brinkmanship
with benefits that are keeping tens of
millions of american families afloat
uh you know it's a reason why we're all
so
despondent and disgusted that they don't
do even the obvious things
you know when i look at what's going on
in dc zack the big
date i see is august 10th because that's
when the senators were supposed to go
back
to their home towns on vacation
and so no i mean you know in theory to
work in their districts and some of them
are up for re-election so those
senators would be working hard um but to
me
they're gonna get it done before that
date because of the fact that
um they're not going to want to force
everyone like that's literally how this
works is what i get so
disgusted by
it's like they looked up and we're like
well we got to be in town until then
anyway so
you know we dragged this thing to the
the deadline
note they did not get it done before
that date
i hope the american people speak loudly
in november
and vote some of these out most
of them if they're not doing anything
now here's
my other question is if let's say you're
president yang right now
there is this is a negotiation right so
there is compromise there is
tactics that both parties play if you're
president like what level that do you
tolerate
you know like there's certain like do
you compromise okay i'll take 500 bucks
because that's better than nothing
or you're driving this down this case if
you're the president and it's in your
parties in control of the senate i i
would go in and say look
where you have to get this deal done
before current benefits expire because
it's going to be extraordinarily
disruptive to folks not knowing what the
heck's going to happen
next week or the next month's rent or
any of that
and so that's on trump and the
republicans you could put a lot of this
on them because
the democrats laid out a clear bill in
may and then if you're the republicans
you disagree with it then you've got to
get to the table sometime between may
and now and freaking get to work
uh so i think that in this case it's
it's on the republicans that
we're at this point uh and if i were
president
i would say look like we got to do our
jobs because
if you look around like america is
falling apart and
if if they can't count on us to shelve
the during this time we're all
going to suffer for it
and that's what's happening is that like
uh you know we're all disgusted and
wanna
uh to have a different type of leader
you know you're seeing it with some of
like the electoral results around the
country too
and you can say whether you know whether
like a random democrat
um is to blame for um the the
dysfunction
uh that's emanating you know from in
this case the senate
um but people are fed up you know and
like that that's
um like our system of government is just
failing us and it really does break my
heart
that what has historically been a source
of strength for us like being a
democracy a representative democracy and
republic
um now it has become so polarized and
locked up and dysfunctional that they
can't even do the obvious in a time of
crisis
we have no national response to the
largest
global crisis since world war ii right
like since
like what we have no response we have
nothing yeah
we're this crazy dysfunctional basket
case and the rest of the world is
looking up being like like my
my parents um my my mom
left the states uh to go to
back to taiwan and in taiwan they're
like essentially zero cases and life is
perfectly normal
like she like fled the us to go
someplace and there are folks i know
like from
uh who are in all other parts of the
world like in in europe and
elsewhere it's the same deal like
they're all like okay that sucked for a
little while but now things are back to
normal the u.s is
going to rage you can see it very
clearly i talked to andy slavitt
this past week and he's right where he's
like look we know what it would take
it would take a total shutdown like no
interstate travel
everyone just stays the home we
send everyone money
and we lock this thing down for eight
weeks
we act like we acted back in march but
we do it
and he said if that was like a 70
lockdown you go to 90
nationwide and you do that for eight
weeks you put us in a coma
you cash everyone out and then you could
come back and
school could resume sports could resume
like whatever you like
religious services could resume because
you would have gotten it down and this
is what other countries did
but we had this sort of weird half-assed
staggered
lockdown that uh and you know folks were
non-compliant
like that that there was this you know
when you talk about andy's
suggestion which i believe is right
uh you look up and you say you know i
just do
do not think that our government or our
people
um like even have the capacity to go
into a 90
lockdown for eight weeks you know it's
like we exhausted whatever capacity
there was
back in march and then if you look at it
now it's just going to just continue
ripping through
various states and and communities uh
until there's a vaccine and even when
there's a vaccine
you know this vaccine is not going to
have like a 90 efficacy you know i mean
like
like it might have like a 40 50 60
percent efficacy um and so like you know
in my mind's eye
and it's not going to have 100
compliance like not like everyone's
going to go out and get a vaccine
so if you imagine it having something
like let's call it a 60
60 efficacy and then 70 percent get it
you're looking at like 42
immunity which may or may not even be um
enough to get you to
hurt immunity uh i mean if you're
vaccinated
and it works then you'd be in better
shape so
so this is the world of the united
states of america circa 2020
where we failed to take our medicine we
failed to take affirmative steps
and then now we're just going to be
suffering through this rolling
wave of sickness and dysfunction and
death and shutdowns
and kids not
going to school and parents wondering
what the hell to do with their child
care
and tens of millions out of work uh and
congress is going to dither i mean that
this is the reality of where we are
november cannot come soon enough brother
cannot come soon enough
um yeah and so some of the the humanity
forward candidates are
freaking winning like uh yeah i'm super
excited about donna eiman who won her
primary um in austin texas and she's
running against this
78 year old incumbent who's all wrong
um in maryland strickland won her
primary in tacoma olympia
and she's gonna be tremendous um she's
in the general now
so there there is a new wave of
legislator
coming up um we just need a whole lot
more of them in a whole lot more places
and then we can start doing things
differently and better
yeah it is amazing to kind of wield this
influence we had from the
the campaign into real life candidates
getting elected and they're probably i
love it it's amazing it's my hope right
now frankly
yeah it's it's it's great because things
are terrible
but i i only feel better when i do
something and so if you're
pissed off too you want to do something
get behind a humanity forward candidate
like donna or maryland because we can
help them win it's been
invigorating for me helping people like
jermaine johnson
win on the state level and now if we can
make that happen in congress then we
become a very very potent political
force that everyone will pay attention
to so check out the humanity forward
candidates at movehumanityforward.com
find one take them under your wing adopt
them make a donation
and you'll feel better in no time and
then you will get excited about some of
these folks who are trying
to do right by people alex morris and
robbie goldstein like the list just goes
on and on it's awesome yeah
it's my that is my hope right now um
which gets me excited
um real quick i'm liking this tweet of
the week thing because
you tweet stuff and it's obviously
whatever 140 characters so there's not
always context and i find them
fascinating and there was one
you tweeted you retweeted an article
from the hill
that talked about an msnbc producer our
favorite network
who uh who quit she had been there for
seven years name is ariana picari i
think
i said her last name um we never
interacted with her much but she left
and saying and this is like i'm
paraphrasing but quoting her
um she said our current model of cable
news with the ratings driver
ratings driven cable news is a cancer
that stokes division blocks diversity of
thought and amplifies
fringe voices for the sake of ratings so
one i'll say on behalf of yank speaks
well done
ariana uh because we agree but thoughts
on
and like quick i feel like we do a whole
episode of this but thoughts on
we've had some beef with msnbc like
thoughts on what you've seen
there and also generally in this
business after running
it's fascinating man i retweeted that
article and i said look it is not an
msnbc thing
it's a broadcast journalism and media
thing
where you just get addicted to ratings
and advertising and then you just do
what works for
your audience you're not trying to cater
to 100 of the public
and ariana one of the most damned
critiques she had was when a producer
said like look we're not really news
we're like comfort uh for
our audience uh and so you don't really
need to wanna hear when i hear what they
wanna what they believe
yeah so just gotta give the people what
they want uh and
um and then if you have that on both
sides and you wind up tearing the
country apart
uh and that's where we are it's it's a
an emblem of the thing that i ran on uh
in action where you have the market just
driving everything in american life and
you have
the the almighty dollar sucking
news coverage in particular directions
and then you have people on the other
side and the people are losing and being
like what the hell happened to the news
like what's going on
and then you have folks and ariana
points it out she said look
like we just always talk about whatever
trump said uh and we did that in 2016
we're doing it now because
it gin's up a reaction gets ratings and
yeah
and that's how we wound up at this mess
and we're still doing it
and what and so
you have to look at it and say okay i
get it you're addicted to
uh dollars and ratings and advertising
and
zach so i retweeted that article and i
was like this seems pretty obvious to me
and you know we got maybe whatever got
like eight nine thousand likes
um and then a couple of media types like
took issue with it
um yeah and and and then and i just got
like
so like someone was like oh the new york
times is successfully transitioning to a
subscription model and i was like
congratulations it's like
the one biggest newspaper like like what
like talk about the thousand local
papers that went out of business and all
the journalists who used to work there
um or or uh someone else said like oh
but like the
you know podcast the long-form stuff's
doing really well for us and being like
well
does that undo the ratings pressures
you're under
or the uh the death of local journalism
or uh like the the fact that
coverage gets skewed in particular ways
i mean
and and that the folks who were talking
about it
were generally speaking fairly prominent
types and and so like i feel like
they've all gotten brain damage
um where like they're in a field where
the water level's been rising
uh and you know in order to survive you
have to contort yourself from these
positions
and so i sent a tweet that was like
really pretty you know
visceral which was like guys like you're
journalists like why don't you freaking
call what's going on
in your industry you're all seeing like
hundreds of your former friends and
colleagues get laid off
like if a young person comes to you and
says they want to be a journalist you're
like no
no you know you're seeing major media
outlets get bought by
tech titans as essentially trophy
properties
or pr plays yeah like i called it a
highbrow indulgence
uh you know like and and you're looking
around being like yeah this is okay
um you know and like and then when
someone points out to you one of your
own
ariana says look we're getting subverted
by the market which the american public
can clearly see is happening
like uh instead some people like go you
know react
like she's like a heretic it's like what
the hell is the matter with you people
you know like you're you're part of a
shrinking industry that's getting
smashed into
this almost unrecognizable form um
and it's subverting our democracy it's
making us
all nuts it's making us all despair and
your job is to
document what's happening um and you
can't document what's happening in your
own
industry in your own backyard
and like and you're all like conditioned
to be like
hey you're like where where are all like
paragons of
uh objectivity we could never be
influenced by the market even as like
you're you're seeing like your behavior
completely gets subverted
like thank goodness for someone like
ariana who just called it
in an honest way and said hey look i see
these decisions all the time
and it's not that the people are bad and
this is like my big message is like
the people in a corrupt
um distorting system will end up
adhering to that system's
incentives and you don't like just throw
rocks the people
you say we need to rewire the software
of that system
so if journalists feel this incredible
pressure to maintain relevance and
ratings and
advertising dollars by inflaming their
audience you have to make it so that
media organizations are not rewarded for
inflaming their audience
maybe they get rewarded for a little bit
more
substantive dry objective boring
you know coverage that delves into yeah
that delves into
uh some and this is something i really
think like i'm
i want to dig into this more and we'll
probably have ariana on and some other
folks
to talk about this because i like
because we're here to solve problems
we're here to like fix the problems of
america
um and you need democracy to make that
happen and in order to have a
functioning democracy you need
some form of media um and if you have
for example local newspapers go out of
business
then you know what suffers democracy
because how can you vote on what's going
on
in your community if there's literally
no one covering what's going on in your
community and then if you want to try
and solve things at a national level
and you have uh this set of problems
then it becomes much much harder so we
have to try and fix what's going on
with the news media if we're gonna have
a chance to fix some of the bigger
problems
uh and i wanna dig into this because i
think it's
it's important and you and i lived it
too that's the other thing is like we
got to experience our own strange
uh gauntlet of yeah
and and we came out of it you know it's
like
like like obviously you know um thanks
to the yang gang thank you like we we
came through it
and our message still reached people uh
you know which would not have been
tested which is good too right like
we're still it's still
relatively relevant or very relevant
when you look at it right now
but we but there needs to be a different
set of incentives in place
if we're going to have journalism and
democracy survive
uh in this country and that's something
that i'm very committed to
it's not that dissimilar from some of
the other issues we try and tackle
and some of the journalists actually
came out in response to my uh argument
and say you're right we need essentially
like a universal basic income for news
like you just need some form of public
funding so that
news organizations can one survive
and to have a set of incentives that are
aligned with the people instead of
aligned with
whatever uh pays the bills at that
moment in time in a time when it's going
to be harder and harder for you to pay
your bills
because guess what no one wants to pay
for your subscriptions anymore
uh and the advertising dollars just keep
getting squeezed and squeezed
um uh certainly online because like the
the digital rates uh just will never
match what you used to get
well here's what's here's what's really
scary about that is the guy that
the guy that started this that came at
you on twitter
is objectively one of the good ones
that's it so his name is sam stein
i love sam stein he's a senior writer of
the daily beast he's one of the first
major outlets to cover us making that
but he wrote the qual like we're about
to qualify for the debate stage one of
the first pieces that came out on us
he helped us blow up when we gave away
money on the debate stage like he is a
friend and a very good journalist
and that is that is the point though
like i got when a guy like sam is saying
hey this isn't that big of a problem
we're evolving
to me he's drinking the kool-aid he's
brainwashed he doesn't see
and like one like your success story
proves the rule to me like oh one like
the new york times can handle like
having some podcasts like sick bro
like look at the rest of the country and
and
just like we go on and on we should go
on and on a different episode but
that to me is a scary part when the good
ones
are not seeing what's happening then
what then we're all screwed
so this needs to be solved and i think
it's a government place to somewhat get
their hands involved
yeah there are a lot of the biggest
problems in american life today like
we've all been so conditioned that
government cannot solve our problems
um which you know we started this
episodes that are talking about
um but the but the impossible position
wherein is that
a lot of these problems require
government to be involved
and in in my ideal world the government
helps set up the
incentives and resources it doesn't make
all the decisions
but it like sets the stage so that the
incentives are better and the structures
are better
the framework if you will um
let's turn to some happier news man
because the interview you have with
joseph gordon-levitt
um segway's in this a lot it talks about
our
our system the incentives of data
companies you talk about data you talk
about art
and here's what so i was a huge huge
angels in the outfield fan so i'm
listening to this conversation man i was
fanboying like so hard i freaking loved
that movie i could quote every freaking
line
um but joseph was um
what i was surprised about is that
he went to i didn't know he went to
columbia in like between becoming a
child actor went to colombia and then
became an adult actor
um and basically famous again if you
will
um and he's really really smart and
thoughtful um
no offense to actors in that stereotype
but i wasn't expecting that level of
intellectual depth maybe i'm a jerk for
saying that but i wasn't expecting it
yeah joe and i connected late
late in the campaign and he's a really
smart thoughtful
creative uh human being it's really
awesome
like he has not been misshapen and we
actually talk a little bit about
the fact that it's like man being a
child actor seems to a lot of
people up like
like how'd you avoid how'd you avoid
that one um
but he's a deep thinker he also got
excited about the data dividend project
when i first
brought it to him and he runs this
massive creative community
hit record oh that you know i admire a
great deal so thrilled with this
conversation
i hope you enjoy it too joseph gordon
levitt on yang speaks
[Music]
yang speaks we think that our data is
ours
uh we should be sharing its value we
should have control over it and
certainly we should know
if big brother is peering over our
shoulder now
in today's day and age that's easier
said than done but one way you can make
sure that your data stays safe and
secure
is by using a vpn and here at yangspeaks
we
recommend expressvpn it's number one
rated by
wired and others it's like using the
internet someplace else magically by
hitting a button
and you can use it to feel like you're a
secret agent
you can use it to access content that's
only available in europe what the hell
are they watching in europe well you can
find out
so just use expressvpn and my link is
expressvpn.com
yang you can get an extra three months
of expressvpn for
free at expressvpn.com
yang
it is my pleasure to welcome to yank
speaks the one the only
joseph gordon levin j hello
[Laughter]
thanks for having me that's great look
at the drum set in the background too
like and i know that that's that's not
just for show you probably
banging out on that this is a good way
to exercise your demons
just hit something as hard as you can
you're not hurting anybody
just maybe your own ears you gotta wear
your protection and yeah drums have been
my uh
my catharsis of choice for many years
now
well whatever keeps you healthy and
balanced man because
that is definitely very up there on like
the uh
positive ways to do so like literally
like a billion
more destructive uh ways to go
um so you you're like this
incredibly prolific creative um
your community hit record is so cool oh
look i've got a prolific creative two
disclaimers
hey dude look at that there's another
daddy let's see we got this hey how's it
going man
all right run on off gamer all right
that doesn't actually happen i think
it's a yang speaks first
nice i'm honored i'm honored oh so
i feel like you and i have a lot in
common where we're both uh
in quarantine you're in la so you know
unfortunately it's been uh quite shut
down there
and you're a dad like me you've got two
young kids right
yes yep my two boys
yeah me too two boys you just saw the
the younger
uh come in um you have this massive
creative community
you're like the sort of leader and
steward of which i think is like the
coolest thing ever
and then you have all of this work
yourself coming out
um which i'd love to hear you talk about
so you and i were talking about how you
have a
labor of love that you were filming
right
um as the pandemic hit yeah exactly
it's a show uh it's gonna come out next
year on apple
that i'm writing and directing and
acting in and uh
been putting it together for years and
we are finally shooting it
and yeah just three weeks into
production is when lockdown arrived
and uh we had to stop and we're gonna
start up again
soon but yeah it was really frustrating
and it took me it took me a second to
realize though
um that as frustrated as i was to have
to stop
shooting this show that i cared so much
about um
a lot of people were going through
things way way worse and
um and from from that point on i
i just was like oh yeah i'm really
grateful to be
able to stay home a lot of people can't
stay home like a good friend of mine
i was just talking to you know he works
at ups
ups can't stop you know and uh you know
of course there's all the yeah all the
medical workers all the people in the
food industry i mean just so many people
that
you know can't stay home like i can and
and then they're keeping the world
spinning around and i'm
incredibly grateful to all of them and
but but
and just trying to stay grateful for
what i have even though like i'm sick of
quarantine and i want to go out and do
other things i
i try to remember like man it's pretty
good it's
really quite good right now for to you
know
my situation i'm lucky
i i can relate 100 on both fronts
because
you're cooped up you're frustrated but
you know how fortunate you are
particularly if you have young kids
running around and at least my kids
really
frankly like are enjoying having mommy
and daddy underfoot all the time because
i'm sure when you were
shooting your show you were probably
busier and
out more would love to hear more about
the show because you
again you've been behind so many
projects over the years and i feel like
for you to put your stamp on
where it sounds like you're directing
writing
and acting in this project then it must
be something you're really excited about
it is yeah this is it's sort of my uh my
chance to do a lot of the
things creatively that i've always
wanted to do and uh
yeah i it's it's it's kind of one of
those dream come true projects from like
wow i'm really getting to do all this
and um i haven't done a series in a long
time i acted in a series when i was
a teenager we remember man we remember a
third rock from the sun
like beeped into our living room yeah
like that's what happened with me at
least
so are you allowed to talk about this
series uh yeah
i haven't talked about it much because
it's not coming out till next year um
there's other things you know coming out
sooner
um but uh but yeah i could i could talk
about it it's um
it's sort of a it's a half hour drama
comedy comedy drama
i was sort of like blurring the lines
between the two because the stuff that's
funniest to me is the real
human stuff more than just like jokes or
gags um
and uh it's it's not about me
exactly but it's not not about me it's
sort of about
uh you know the character's name is josh
corman not joseph gordon
um and uh and it it came from me
thinking about
kind of what we were just talking about
feeling really grateful for the life i
have and wondering like you know it
didn't necessarily have to go this way
uh i i could have just as easily ended
up
not successful in show business i don't
i don't think that like
you know i worked hard and i think i'm
good at what i do but there's lots of
people that work hard and that are good
what they do that don't
don't you know succeed at show business
the way that i've been lucky enough to
um i i feel like i'm lucky to have met a
woman i love so much and gotten to start
a family you know i i
a a lot of people i know that are
wonderful people
just haven't found their person yet and
that that could have just as easily
happened to me and so it just got me
thinking about wow i'm so grateful for
some of these huge things in my life and
and
what if my life were a little different
and and i started coming up with this
character who's
a lot like me grew up in the san
fernando valley a suburb of los angeles
just like me
went to van nuys high just like me um
is sort of artistically inclined just
like me but uh
his career didn't work out and he works
as a public school teacher
and he's good at it and loves it and
being a teacher is something i've always
sort of been really interested and
thought i'd be good at and thought it
was something i'd i'd like to try but i
i just haven't because i've been focused
on my lucky career in show business and
um and he's trying to find love and you
know
just not working for him which is i've
spent many years of my life before i
found my wife
feeling that way and he's just doing his
best to you know be a good person and
and be happy but it's hard and uh
that's that's really what the show's
about no that that's so fun so you've
been working on this for a while
and then you found a partner in apple i
feel like apple's like the
big new funder
they showed up but they're just like all
right let's buy our way into this stuff
yeah silicon valley is basically taking
over hollywood
they've almost already taken it over
entirely and
with you know if it's not already all
done it's it's
it's almost there the only real holdout
is disney they're like
they're the only company left that's a
hollywood company that's not been
bought up by by a bigger tech company
really well this is something i'd love
to talk to you about
um because you and i connected earlier
on our concern about how our data is
getting used
uh and one thing that i'm um
seeing that you pretty much what you
just expressed is that
content is essentially getting
commoditized
uh where you have these tech companies
that
have much much greater higher levels of
resources than like any of the studios
and so that they control these pipes
they have these connections to asana
devices
and and then they're just trying to now
absorb content
and like funnel it through their
platforms and
and devices and so like a lot of the
traditional
creativity i feel like um is coming
under the tech umbrella
and you feel a little bit like these
tech companies
you know netflix being the most i know i
enjoy netflix
um but certainly there's like the sense
that netflix is like
is scratching its chin being like like
what what what would you enjoy what do
you desire
they have like this near limitless
budget and you actually have a movie
coming out on netflix i think um
you know just a couple weeks which is
which i confess to being somewhat
excited about so i'm not like sorry
it's a great one we can talk about that
too i
and i really like i really like netflix
actually and i really like apple too
um and to me one of the important things
to to distinguish between netflix and
apple and then some of the other
giants in the field that you're talking
about that are building the pipes like
you say
is um both netflix and apple
have a direct relationship with the
consumer meaning like the people
watching their
content are their customers we have
elected netflix it's true like we've
given them our credit card we've been
like all right laying on me yeah
but but not that's not the case
everywhere and
um like i know you're a fan of jaron
lanier and and
his thinking has informed mine a lot in
in this regard
but you know a lot of the pipes that
you're talking about
it's not the people using the pipes that
are
actually paying for the pipes meaning uh
it and it's it's largely google and
facebook and and look this isn't to be
you know be shitty towards google and
facebook and there's lots of amazing
things that happen on facebook or
instagram or google or youtube like lots
of beautiful art lots of
wonderful people that work at those
places but i do think that
the the model where the users
aren't paying money the users get these
services for free
in exchange to be spied on on mass
and and be kind of manipulated through
these
incredibly powerful machine learning
algorithms that are feeding into all
this big data and using behaviorist
techniques to you know
quote unquote advertise people um if
that's the business model that
that really does make me worried and
i you know there's like jaron talks a
lot about
how that's impact how that could impact
economies how that could impact
democracies and i i'm less an expert on
those things that you you've spoken
really eloquently about that
as well it's one of the things i've been
such a fan of yours for
but um where i where i feel like i have
some expertise is like
i think that model that kind of
attention economy
model is really bad for the creative
spirit
yeah i think it's that's where
creativity out of your heart
and i and i agree with you too that
netflix and apple are sort of different
animals than
facebook and google in this regard or
youtube uh you know if
you look at it um because netflix and
apple
we essentially pay subscription fees and
then in apple
in in netflix's case it's like look i've
got millions of subscribers i've got all
this money like i just need to
keep a content pipeline going that keeps
all them happy and gets more people that
want to pay me
uh and and then youtube is like the
opposite model essentially where it's
like hey
no one pays anything but you're gonna
pay
through the fact we're gonna try and
monetize your attention everywhere you
go and uh you know we're gonna try and
bombard you with ads
and if you're a creator to that point
you get paid like
you know like like uh scintilla of a
penny
[Laughter]
for every view um and one thing i really
appreciate about you is that so you're
like up here in the entertainment
ecosystem you know you can like oh
that's very cutty
no i mean just just to this fact it's
like you have a series you're shooting
for apple you have this movie coming out
on netflix it's like the two giant
content walled gardens
um that are developing but you're also
the steward of this creative community
because you just want more people to be
able to create
um so you have this thriving uh group of
creators on hit record um
and then you know they're not like you
know signing like you know
like uh apple or netflix deals they're
putting their stuff on youtube
um and so you see how the system's not
working for
the up-and-comers who are just trying to
make art and put their work out there
that like
this uh ecosystem is really
uh exploiting them in many ways like
it's you know just like
trying to extract value um and then
they're they're hoping that they can
sort of make it through this narrowing
gate
like the like the up and coming
creatives and i just had this
social media discussion um around
musicians
which is like another thing where it
like uh if you look at
something like music to me i mean the
music industry i always
i've always known has also like massive
problems but it was
clear to me that if you were a
successful musician or even like an
up-and-coming musician
um touring was where you were going to
make your money like certainly if you
were like someone who could sell out a
venue
but even if you were you know a lower
level musician you could like
tour and like make your bones and so i i
just tweeted i was like
i have no idea how any musician makes
money right now because like you know it
seems like most touring is off the table
um and then this whole cavalcade of
musicians then came into the stream
being like yeah like none of us make
anything
because like the streaming royalties are
our pennies
i'd say the number one concern that
most of us have during this pandemic is
just trying to stay positive and healthy
throughout
you know a lot of the days blend in with
each other and one way you can take
better care of yourself
and make sure you're eating right is to
join freshly
they send you food that's pre-prepared
it's
delicious it's easy if you don't know
how to cook
it's perfect just order freshly
and they send you the food you eat it
and you feel better about yourself
because it wasn't crap
that's really like you could maybe
freshly should rebrand itself
not crap because because i have to say
um for whatever reason it's so easy to
eat crap right now i don't know about
the rest of you it's like you go down
you go to that kitchen and whatever is
there is just like oh sure
you just want to freaking shovel it into
your mouth so
instead you can shovel fresh cooked
healthy food into your mouth with
freshly
it makes you feel a lot better you wake
up the next day feeling
great and freshly.com is offering our
listeners 40
off for their first two orders at
freshly.com
yang that's freshly.com look invest in
yourself
invest in your health this is a
no-brainer
for folks who aren't exactly tearing it
up in the kitchen
or on the treadmill right now which i
suspect
is most all of us so andrew my apartment
building has not had gas for like
a year and i'm in a war with the
management company
um because you can't cook and so freshly
has been a godsend because i don't have
any other options
um that's remotely healthy so
if you're my management company and
you're listening to this screw you
um and for those of you who are not the
vast majority who are not
related to my management company check
out freshly because
um not being physically able to cook has
led me to freshly.com so fresh.com
yang check it out
[Applause]
um so would love to hear about your
experience with hit record because i
just think it was so
generous of you and it's not like
something that you've worked on only for
a little period of time like you've
worked on it for
i think at this point it's like a decade
and a half old is that right yeah
kind of yeah i mean really a decade old
since it's been like a professional
operation of sorts and
but like five years of just hobby time
before that and
in those earliest earliest days it
started
before it was a company or a website or
anything uh it was just this
kind of turn of phrase i would say to
myself hit record because
um i needed creative inspiration
and uh because i've been an actor ever
since i was a kid
and i went to college i quit acting for
a while
uh to go to school and then when i
wanted to get back into acting i
couldn't get a part
uh no one would cast me in anything and
it was super
painful to want to express myself
and not be given permission to do that
and
and so hit record was just this little
metaphor i came up with like i'm going
to be the one to hit the record button
and it's sort of a play on the you know
the older phrase of
a hit record and and sort of trying to
in my
in my in my way say something about how
media is changing from
a commercial object like a hit record
into a a creative action sorry a
commercial object like a hit record
into a creator we got you we got you
like hitting record
and um that was my like bit of wordplay
but again it wasn't like it wasn't
anything other than just my own sort of
thing i'd say to myself when i wanted to
be creative and and i learned how to
uh i learned how to edit videos and i
started making little short films and
songs and stories and stuff and then my
brother helped me set up this little
website to share some of what i was
doing and it was just yeah it was
like 2005. so this was a little bit
before it was so common to just post on
a
on youtube or a blog or whatever and we
we started our own website and we called
it hitrecord.org and
slowly but surely this this community
started to form on the website because
we had this little like
prefab message board on there like a php
message board
and what we found from the people that
were coming to
this little message board was some of
them wanted to just come and check out
the little things i was making but what
a lot of people wanted to do
was collaborate not just look
but make things together with me and
with each other and
and my brother and i at that time
thought
that's unique to this moment in history
that people all over the world
could not only be watching the same
thing but could
come together and make something
together that they might not have been
able to make on their own
um and and you know oftentimes new
technology
is used to imitate old technology
yeah you know using the internet to
watch a video in many ways is imitating
television using the internet to read
a bug is in many ways imitating a
magazine or newspaper or whatever
just like when movies first came out
they mostly imitated
theater and when the printing press
first came out they mostly imitated
books but the internet could be
something more than just a place to
watch
and and consume and collaboration felt
like
oh that's what that's the that's what
this is really for
and so we leaned into that but at first
in a completely informal way it was just
something my brother and i were doing as
a hobby
he he's a coder and uh he started
writing little bits of code on top of
this message board to try to help
this small community collaborate on
little creative art projects
and it grew and it grew and eventually
my friend jared and i
started a production company and said
like hey this is happening in this
community
we could do bigger more ambitious things
where where
what we all make together can be a book
that we publish or it could be a tv show
that gets on tv or a record we put out
and
and we can figure out ways if any of
these productions make money then
the artists all share in that money and
um and that's what we did we
that's what we've been doing for years
and and now we're really focused on
trying to
to really make the tech a lot better so
that it's not always me
and and the folks in my office leading
those projects but that anybody can come
and start their own project and find
their collaborators and
and have a collaborative creative
experience because
ultimately what i've found is like going
back to the origins of it if you're
looking to just
express yourself to to have that
have that creative experience where like
i want to do
something it's hard to do it alone i
find it's it's real
personally i find it hard to do alone
and i think a lot of people find it hard
to do alone
whereas if you can jump in on a project
with other people
then you've got other people that are
saying like okay i'll do this and you do
that and you're holding each other
accountable
you're giving each other encouragement
and feedback and and you
it's not just it's it's also less like
daunting to be like
hey world hey internet here's me and my
thing come
like me you know it's more like hey
we're we made something together it's
it's like it helps i think people come
out of their shell and
it's um it's more complicated than like
posting something on your own that you
can do on you know youtube or tik tok or
instagram or whatever but um and so it's
it's
it's taken us a long time and it's still
a process figuring out how to make that
all work
how to help people collaborate with each
other um but it's
it's just continued to grow and grow and
more people are doing it now than ever
and
um it it continues to be something i
find deeply fulfilling and so
yeah i i i think it's awesome you know
the yang gang
has like a creative strain as well
certainly we have nothing like you know
what you've
built but but there's like a you know a
group of like artists and
designers and um one of the things that
i think
is was true in my campaign is that this
is not enough art in the world
in part because of what you and i are
just describing where like the market
doesn't support
enough art uh yeah this is something
i've always wanted to ask you about and
i've been
excited to ask you about it since i've
gotten to know you a bit and now's maybe
a good time
um because i i heard you on a podcast a
while back when when you were first
um campaigning for president and and you
were talking about
universal basic income but then you were
also saying
like and you you could don't even put
words in your mouth you could express
this better than i could but you were
talking about like
having other programs and structures to
support
kind of productivity and like
community driven collaborative efforts
whether it's in art or in other
fields that were not necessarily driven
by
a commercial market but um but we're
driven by other modes of oh yeah yeah
i'm so interested in how that works
because i don't know that
commerce is the only way to drive art
yeah thank you for calling that out uh
so
to me pillar number one is like put
money into people's hands
would folks have more freedom to create
yes would they have more ability to
reward artists and creators yes if you
had better structures in place
but there's like this whole set of
activities that
has been eroding for years and decades
the united states of america
that we i think most of us agree are
like pretty positive stuff that the
market
just is not going to love and one thing
that
like you know i use as an example when i
travel is like local papers local
newspapers
local newspapers are getting wiped out
like you know a thousand local paper is
gone
and democracy does not function as well
if you don't have local papers
uh so let's let's say even if we had
more money in a community
sure some more local papers would
survive but maybe you decide that
local journalism is good regardless of
whether or not like the advertising
makes money or you know like the
subscriptions
and so if you start looking at some
things that maybe we can agree are
positive which i would definitely put
art in this category
i'd put local journalism in this
category i put volunteering for
a civic organization um in this category
and so volunteerism is
down like pretty much anything where
like there's something that you
regard as positive in the community has
been declining by the numbers
for years and so there's like this whole
suite of activities
where i don't think any of us
necessarily wants to get quote unquote
paid for everything
it's like hey if i you know volunteer
for the non-profit like nonprofit pay me
it's like like there has to be like some
sort of activity you do that's like
non-monetary but also um something that
we
we want to reward or reinforce and so my
idea was essentially you create like a
parallel
economy around this other set of
activities
that could that we could use another
currency for or time
um and it was based on something called
time banking where
um in the 60s rfk's speechwriter was
trying to figure out how to help
um poor communities become more socially
connected
and what they came up with was something
called time banking where if i
babysit your kids then you get me back
by hauling like logs off my lawn
and we essentially just trade like units
of time with each other
um and so you could introduce like a
different currency or
time units into this other set of
activities
that we know we need more of but you
don't want to pay people for
because it's like a little messed up
[Laughter]
so and and i would certainly put art
in this category where if someone
produces public art
then they would get uh you know this
other
currency reward or other people get them
back in various ways
it'd be a way to try and stitch together
uh social interactions
and and and also you could disclose it
publicly in a way that you don't money
so if i'm like hey i made a thousand
bucks like i'm an if i'm like
waving around like my thousand dollars
my head but if i got these like
you know um a thousand
um social points or whatever you call
them
um then you could actually broadcast it
in a way that everyone finds perfectly
socially acceptable
um and then you could even give those
social points to someone else
um and uh and then they could use it for
various things so that was like the
thinking around like uh
that like you you need something
non-monetary for
certain activities that you want to help
see more of
can i ask you more about how that will
work i know you haven't like fleshed it
out entirely so
this is maybe just a totally
hypothetical situation but i just find
that
so fascinating i want to ask you more
about like so in in the case of an
artist say because that's obviously
what's
close to my heart and experience so
someone
who who makes some art say they make a
song
they record a song and it's it's not
necessarily like the kind of
commercially viable song
that uh a record label is going to
invest in or something
but they they have the potential to earn
this sort of whether it's like time time
banking or social points or
whatever you call it how there there
would have to be what some kind of
system in place that would determine
whether how many social points that song
is
worth or like how would that kind of so
my thinking on this and this is actually
very close to the conversation i was
having with the musicians online
um would be that if i listen to the song
just by virtue of my listening to the
song you get
like a social credit uh uh for the fact
that i listen to it
it's like essentially a micro payment
thing okay so everybody who listens to
it
then that right okay so it does have to
do with
um the audience that you garner for the
art that you create
yeah right but so because right now
the way that you can make money
uh or get any kind of compensation for
that sort of thing is say you put your
song
on youtube or your video on youtube or
whatever
and youtube is able to if if
a million or more people come and watch
your videos youtube might make enough
money on ads that they'll give you like
a few bucks
um well this is this is the distinction
you drew initially
um joseph because i've been struggling
with how the heck we got we would get
this done on a
you know societal level you essentially
want the world to look more like netflix
than youtube
right right it's like where we're paying
but in this case
you don't necessarily want and and i
think like tier one
which would be better is if we all had
money and we're all paying
for stuff but then tier two would be
like hey i'm paying with my attention
and you can take like this attention
currency and use that for various things
too
um some of which could be monetary um
because you want to try and get the like
because right right now people are
conditioned to consume art and content
for free or near free
um and then you pay you then you pay a
subscription and then you're like okay
now i'm in the walled garden and i get
like the cool
like uh movie or tv show from like the
the joseph
levitz of the world and so what you want
to do is you want to create like
like closer to that walled garden
dynamic um out there
like uh where if you pay attention to
something then the creator is getting
rewarded
um and it doesn't necessitate my
whipping out my credit card
right right because someone has spent
their time
on your art so if it were time banking
it would be that
that kind of thing yeah yes and so like
that the time actually has value
um and then and then if people have
elected to spend their time on your art
then you actually like build up this
time currency
that you you know you could trade for
dollars
like you know there could be like an
exchange rate essentially
right so and in order for that to happen
it would just it would have to be
kind of top down right like the
government would have to say okay there
is
the government is just like the
government does with dollars like
dollars is a top-down thing the
government
says we the united states government are
deciding that u.s dollars are
valuable right and and so you're saying
that like
the the government would have to say
we're also saying now that
time is valuable and here is a like
government-built structure like
institution for
how we can exchange
time currency so here's where it gets
interesting
that time banking is an effect right now
in hundreds of communities around the
country like that they're just doing it
informally they have some ledger they'll
keep keep track of it um and there are
also
some apps uh like there's one called sev
exchange they have karma points
there are different things where they're
starting to try and monitor this
so if you were a foundation or
philanthropy or a billionaire or whatnot
i know some of these characters so this
isn't entirely hypothetically
like could you go in and say hey guys
guess what
like we're going to essentially
guarantee your time currency at like a
certain exchange
um and uh so if you do something for
someone you develop
you know you get get a credit or you
produce public art and people want to
reward it
um and then if you want like we've got
like essentially like an exchange bank
and i'm going to monetize it to the tune
of a million bucks 10 million bucks
whatever it is
uh and and the fun thing about this is
that you could potentially
create like like a hundred million worth
of uh interactions or social activity
with like a much smaller level of money
um but you would need to essentially do
it within a community the same way that
communities are doing it with time
banking right now
i agree with you in a macro level you'd
probably need the government uh
lending a hand like if you wanted to do
it like throughout the entire us economy
and you were dealing with like massive
numbers but you could pilot this in a
community
um certainly in terms of in-person
activities
and it's happening now uh and then the
trickier thing which is something that i
genuinely think that we need to be
investing a ton of energy
and resources on is how to make it
happen in the digital
universe is how to make it so that like
your time is actually
monetizable in a different way than
advertising because we have to face
facts that right now
so much of our internet uh enjoyment or
whatever is based on advertising
and there was a period when it seemed
like okay this is cool like i've got
you know free facebook free youtube free
this um but now it's degenerated into
this form of
pernicious surveillance capitalism
and among other problems it's absolute
for creators
yes yeah i think it really is and
and it's not just um
it's not just the ads it's what
comes with the ads like
you mentioned the difference between
like a netflix and a youtube and again
i'm saying again there's lots of great
stuff on youtube
i love youtube i i look at youtube all
the time and i find
amazing things i never would have been
able to find anywhere else like
youtube's incredible but there there is
a difference between
what youtube will recommend versus what
netflix will recommend because there's a
difference between how they're
monetizing
the viewers that netflix is
trying to serve viewers something that's
so good and meaningful to them that
they're willing to pay out of their
pocket for it whereas youtube is trying
to serve up things
that are just gonna like catch your
attention and keep your attention
and it doesn't have to be it doesn't
have to be
so profound or meaningful that you would
pay money for it that doesn't
it doesn't have to be that it just has
to kind of catch you enough
to keep your attention and those are two
different
offerings that are that are a result
of those two different models and i
i like as an artist i i'm much more
interested
in making art not that's just going to
catch someone's attention and kind of
like
hook them and keep their attention i'm
interested in making stuff that's
going to be really meaningful to
somebody that they're going to think
about afterwards it's going to like
they're going to remember and you create
different work
based upon one goal and the other the
other thing is that
if you do succeed in catching someone's
attention
even for like x minutes and then
afterwards you're like okay like what
did i
get like as the creator i mean right now
you know in many cases it's uh next to
nothing or nothing
um and and then that doesn't create like
an ecosystem that enables that artist to
like
do something else reinvest you know like
pay themselves
have health care like you know
like what are the basics that we'd
expect anyone who's working
you know creatively to have
[Music]
if you're a parent right now you are
concerned about
a lot of things where your kids learning
education
health environment and one thing you can
do that will make an immediate
difference
is join litterati it's the leading kids
book club in america
it sends you and your child five new and
unique kids books every month you don't
have to do anything you set and forget
it
and then these books arrive and then you
open it your child
is pumped about bedtime and story time
this was made for parents like you if
you're busy you're tied up
and you want a subscription book club
that makes it easy just to find
unique and interesting books for your
kids straight to your doorstep
i'm a big fan who would not be a big fan
of freaking kids creative books getting
sent to your home
if you are a parent and you love your
child you should
join literati uh if you don't i don't
know what it says about you as a parent
you have to
if you love your child um if you don't
have a child
uh join too then send it to someone with
a child
yeah that that's yeah that's probably
overboard but for a limited time
i don't have kids yeah that's not for me
but my friends you're like i swear by
literary fully endorsed
it does make a great gift if you have
friends with the kids and you don't have
don't have kids
so for a limited time go to literary.com
yang for 25
off your first two orders that's the
best offer available anywhere
to get it you have to go to literary.com
yang for 25
off your first two orders how do you
spell literati if you don't know you're
not literati
but it's uh it's spelled like it sounds
[Applause]
literary.com
joseph you said something that i'm
interested in and this this is somewhat
personal so
you know um so you're you grew up a
child actor
uh you know you're on our tv sets and
then it sounds like you went to college
at columbia university in the city for
like uh you know
a period of time um and then you said
you came out
uh and and then people weren't hiring
you maybe because they thought of you as
that child actor and there was like a
difficult transition
into uh you know like fully formed uh
like um like masculine actor that you
know
what whatever it is for hollywood to put
a gun in my hand let's just
put it so sorry that was dark
no no no no not at all no we understand
um so you you strike me
as like a healthy well-adjusted creative
dad like
relationships i feel like being a child
actor
breaks you know x percentage of
folks um you know let's call it
60 or whatever the number is like you
know and i'm sure you grew up with
people that
um went through a version of this um
like i i became
a public figure relatively recently but
i was already like a dad and like fairly
you know
mature so i actually now have a better
understanding as to how it messes people
up
um and i think you became famous in the
time before social media so
good on you you didn't have that
particular
um but but would love to hear about your
transitions that way
like going back to school how did you
find colombia because i went to law
school there so i know the environment
somewhat
and my my wife went there um undergrad
um so so you know it's like so i get
some of
um what that school's about but i'm
curious about the transition both
into college and then out of college and
and coming back to hollywood
yeah i mean a big part of quitting for
me and wanting to go to school was
was getting away from the kind of
attention that you get
with quote-unquote fame fame something
i've thought about a lot because yeah
i've been on on tv and in movies and
stuff ever since i was young
and um there's undeniably something
very seductive and attractive about it
and it's i think it's pretty deep seated
in our biology and it makes sense if
you're out in the wild
and you're living in a tribe of animals
and everyone in your tribe knows who you
are
and has some kind of emotional
attachment to you you're probably more
likely to survive so that's attractive
you want that
and and so i think we have just a basic
animal
attraction to that kind of attention and
fame
um but to verify what you just said
i remember i was reading something where
it said that if you have primates in
captivity
they'll actually pay food to see
pictures
of higher status primates wow
i have not heard that that's incredible
i want to see that study
geez so because there was a time when
you look up and you're like oh celebrity
culture like
you know um like uh not very
uh natural but then when you see that
study you're like holy
apparently celebrity culture is like the
most natural thing in the world
it's very very natural but let's let's
be honest chimpanzees rape and murder
each other all day long
in the wild you know there's a lot of
things that are natural that
we oh yeah i'm not saying it's a good
thing but it is hardwired into us
it is it's hardwired into us and like
there's a lot of those things that are
hardwired into us that part of what like
being a human is about is figuring out
like how much am i going to
be swayed by this this primal monkey
instinct
to you know to act on these
urges and that yeah there is an urge
to to want to be famous and i've i've
felt it i'm drawn to it i
it's something i'd probably struggle
with to be honest like on a daily basis
how much does this matter to me how much
should it sway my decisions
you know and uh how much can i be happy
without it
it's it's hard it's it sounds funny to
say it's hard because it's a real
privilege to have
to have it but it'll mess people up
quick it really does mess people up and
i've uh
it it's i i'm not above saying like it's
probably messed me up to some degree i
do my best to have it not mess me up too
much i've seen it mess other people up
way worse
um for a lot of reasons and and it's
part of what is actually
makes me really concerned about the way
that online culture
is moving right now which is just and
look there's something really wonderful
about kind of
democratizing fame i think that in a way
that's great fame like something like
that shouldn't be limited to just
hollywood and or other like you know
super affluent
metropolises throughout you know the
world it it
it should be like that i i
should be at more accessible to
everybody and and the internet
allows for that accessibility
but what it also does is it
it brings those kinds of struggles and
that kind of
addiction into con at
everyone's life and
uh especially with with younger people i
i
i really because i i was going through
this when i was in junior high
uh not because of social media but
because i was in angels in the outfield
i dealt with like the kind of self-doubt
and questions of like do people really
like me for me or do they like me
because i was in this movie and how can
i know
if i'm really worth anything or if if
it's all about these appearances and
like
is is there any me there at all if i
stop doing these appearances
like give everyone like you know forget
about me turn on me etc exactly and so
and and that was that made junior high
like it was it made it angst written for
me and of course
junior high's angst written for
everybody for lots of reasons but
i don't know i i am i when i see
especially younger people
experiencing some of the same kind of
addiction to
fame and attention that i think like
people in hollywood have experienced for
generations now
it worries me it makes me feel like we
should be worried
you know yeah like you have teenage kids
like you know having like their entire
high school class like following them
into their bedroom like you know on
their smartphone or whatever i mean like
you know
like that that's a very intense
experience that
previously think of yourself differently
if
you are a performance and there's no
boundary there then like the most
important thing in life i think
especially as a younger person but it's
something i
still very much believe in as a you know
dad now
you have to have your own like
your own relationship with yourself
you have to have that space where you
are you and you know who you
are and you are who you are because of
your own preferences and your own
feelings and your own beliefs
and if that goes away because you're
you're constantly offered opportunities
to present a performance version of
yourself
and get the dopamine hits that you get
when people you know hit the heart
button and
like you or retweet you or whatever it
you it's it's easy to lose track
of that core relationship that you have
with yourself
it's and it's you got to spend time
alone
you have to spend time just going
deep down into yourself and ignoring
what
anybody says because ultimately yeah as
kurt cobain says
all we are is all alone or all alone is
all we are you ultimately you're the
only
you are the only one and everybody else
no matter how close you get and like i
feel
deeply deeply close with like my family
but
it's there there is no matter what
there's a difference between
that relationship you have inside your
own
head and it's precious and it's it's a
part of what makes us human and it's
loseable
it's so losable if you never spend any
time on it if you spend all your time
for others presenting yourself to others
wow man that's really profound and deep
and correct uh you know i mean i've just
i mean i've just gotten
like a glimpse of it myself uh i
i fear for what we're doing to a lot of
these kids brains
um and sense of self because i certainly
never felt
that visible and on display when i was
a kid you know it's like i was a shy
bookworm and
you know go home close the door and read
my fantasy novel
yeah that's important i did that too and
you asked like how come i'm
like not addicted to drugs or or you
know
in jail or something like unfortunately
a certain number of kids who experience
fame
are i think a lot of it is because i was
encouraged and did have time to just
like be by myself and read that fantasy
novel and and like just have that
time with myself and not not just be
always obsessed with
what do other people think of me how can
i present myself to more and more people
and what should that presentation be and
um it gets convoluted so much with art
too that's the other thing i
i i i've experienced something like this
even um so i'm trying to get universal
basic income across the finish line
and one of the things that happened on
the campaign trail and like and that you
can relate to this
is that like people uh people need a
person
to like pin it on you know so it's like
if i want this thing to happen then it's
gonna have to be
me like making the case talking to
people
saying hey we should really do this and
there's like this continued projection
outward
you know that that like that you have to
do and not to say i'm like i'm not like
an artist or creative in the same way
but like
i there are some parallels because like
you have to continuously like project
this energy out uh and
like it and like th this with the
struggle you're describing and
creativity go hand in hand because like
sometimes you
like there are creatives who are like
look i just like my work to speak for
itself
but unfortunately like just no one
operates that way
not as much these days yeah yeah it's
like like there are there are a few and
i admire the hell like donald glover for
example
not on twitter not on instagram i have
so much admiration for that and
yeah donald um you know i don't you
probably know this but they had like
donald and i are friendly and he
uh came out from my campaign i i visited
with him in la and like
i didn't know that oh that's that's cool
i i admire him so much that's great
oh yeah yeah he he endorsed me and uh we
did like a pop-up collaboration where we
he like
his people designed like this sweet uh
gang gang gear it was like this 1k
theme sort of like urban um and so we
did like a pop-up
shop appearance together i was super
grateful to him because he endorsed me
when
uh you know it was like still um
i i guess it wasn't that mainstream a
thing to do but like but
when when i talked to him um
he was just like yeah i can see where
things are going
[Laughter]
that i was like oh well fantastic thank
you donald yeah
um yeah but i'm with you it was also
like part of his uh
his um humanity that he's like eschewed
uh social media and other ways to to get
his work out there just lets the work
stand
yeah well and that it's it's such an
important thing i think too
as an artist and and nowadays it look
again
it's wonderful that anybody can take
whatever their art is a piece of writing
or a video they made or whatever and
post it and have and have that audience
that's that
is a wonderful thing but there is this
this other side that comes along with it
that if you're always thinking of art
in terms of audience there's a part of
the creative process that's
that you'll miss that like all the great
artists forever have
all experienced where they're just
making something for themselves that no
one's ever gonna see because they're
they're probably young or they they
haven't had their you know their career
hasn't
started yet or whatever and they're just
sitting in their room playing or or
writing or doing their thing and it's
and it's a it's a mode of
self-exploration it's not
for anybody else it's how you get in
touch with that self of
that i was talking about a second ago
that to me is such a valuable part
of what art and creativity is and
it's part of what we really try to
celebrate with hit record with
when we say let's emphasize the process
as one of our communities core values is
enjoy the process like
doing this together with other people we
are helping
each other just stay in this flow of the
artistic process and it's
yes we want to finish something and make
something and celebrate it with the rest
of the community but
so much of it is just the process of
like staying up all night and
and being like what what is the exact
right way to tell the next beat of this
story and then you find it and like
when those exhilarating moments they're
not about
an audience applauding for you they're
about your own
success that you yes you figured
something you figured it out you know
you found it
it's about like that struggle and that
exploration and the big problem right
now is like we essentially
uh wait for the market to tell us
whether something was good and valuable
right and it's it's destroying us you
know like
uh so so my my run too it's like there
was a time when it was
you know people uh laughed at me or
thought it was like completely marginal
and then we
reached a level of mainstream success
and the thing i always think about is
like look
like i'd be the same person if i
wasn't if i hadn't gone on joe rogan and
like hadn't caught fire and
the rest of it like i wouldn't be like
you know worse human being if my
campaign had gone
nowhere if anything i might even bet a
better human being
if my campaign had gone nowhere yeah and
i might be a better artist
i i honestly think that if i just been
making my own stuff this whole time and
not
had a commercial career i mean i think
there would be ups and downs because
my commercial career has allowed me to
collaborate with other incredible
artists
um but it also does it has meant that
i've spent time doing things that have
taken me away from
what might have been more kind of unique
to me
well that's to be like a reasonable
summary of why we're
uh tearing each other apart and getting
destroyed
um is that right now like i and i said
this on the trail too it's like
if you have money on one side in america
and then humanity on the other
like money's winning like all of
our behavior all of our systems like our
government our medicine our
culture like everything is just getting
like sucked into like this money
black hole and then over here you have
like humanity
i'd certainly put art here i'd put our
kids mental health
i'd put like like the the struggle in
the process regardless of the outcome
uh you know like good people and losing
causes
you know it's one reason why like now
like i'm trying to help these candidates
some of whom
you know like like other uh national
figures would be like well this person's
chances are too low
and i'm just like i don't really care
what their chances are like
are they like a good person like do i
believe in them
you know maybe i should start there in
part because when i came up
i think i received zero political
endorsements
from any elected official um because
elected officials did not want to touch
like the magical asian man who wanted to
give everyone
they had you know like like and they had
like pre-existing political
relationships so they're looking around
being like oh i should endorse this
person because i'll like get some
currency
and then the the coin flipped where now
i have currency because thank you yang
yang but like
that now there are like you know
hundreds of thousand people are going
into my campaign and i've got like a
bigger mailing list than
you know like uh like anyone except for
a handful of national figures
so so then all of a sudden like like
that it's like oh
like now like gang is like politically
useful um and so
like so like if you have money on one
side humanity on the other like
humanity's losing
and like we have to take it back as
quickly as possible like
the software this machine like the the
so the black hole is like gathering mass
you know it's one of those things where
like as the mass grows
like it gets more powerful and you can
see these like desperate like clawing
gestures for help on the other side
where they're like hey
like can we not like all like have our
you know like behavior or healthcare or
government or anything like
determined by what the market likes and
doesn't like you know it's like maybe we
should have post offices because we like
post offices even if they don't make
money
we should just like decide like on a few
things it's like you know we think
that's a good idea
even if it it like you know isn't paying
for itself or whatever
yeah like that everybody should have
medicine yeah
everything needed medicine maybe in a
pandemic it'd be a good idea we all
didn't have uh have to worry about
payment um
and and this thing is it's it's
certainly i think it's happening
in art in its own way that's like really
um
it's powerful like and it's complicated
so it's not 100 clear because like you
said there are like positive
democratizing
effects you know so and so like you do
have folks like making beautiful things
and like
you know making a living off of them in
innovative ways
um and so it's not all bad um but it's
like the complicated stories of the ones
that i
i think are like um like the the
toughest peop for people to see
um but certainly for for me right now
like i look up at like
you know like the death of live music
and i think is this going to be like
terrible for musicians yes
like i look at like what's going on in
terms of the way artists and creatives
get rewarded and i'm like is this going
to be bad over time when there are like
a handful of
mega corps that we all like
subscribe to and they're like feeding us
our uh our stuff
um yeah it's what what i'm still trying
to fight uh and i
you know i have a few hopes for the
future still
um a few levels i really believe in it
man i really agree with what you're
saying and i'm i'm no economist but i
i from what i've learned yeah
the free market is the the best
foundation for an economy but if but
without
other things that temper the free market
then
it just turns into this black hole like
you're talking about
the winner take all the consolidation
yeah yeah and
just not everything in life is going to
be
properly incentivized by free market
capitalism or purely free market
capitalism we can we can be
we can have a good free market
capitalist
economy but also have other stuff that
tempers that and and builds on top of
that
to make sure that the other things in
life that we care about that aren't so
easily monetized
can still be part of our life because
otherwise
everything's just yeah number one you
make everyone actually a participant or
stakeholder in like
you know the the market economy by
saying look like
like i don't care who you are like you
you're entitled to a certain
uh amount and then you have to try and
build some counterweight to like this
stuff
uh you know like build a counterweight
that um
that helps humanize things really like
we're losing
our humanity progressively and it's one
reason why
i like i appreciate and admire you so
much is that you've been in environments
and had like this
incredible career that i feel like would
have dehumanized
99.9 of humans by the way like you
yeah but but like you but you you still
seem
grounded positive um
healthy productive caring uh empathetic
you know you've got and i think one of
the things that keeps you empathetic is
that you you
you do have like all of these creatives
in this community that
you're the the leader of and and i'm in
a similar boat where it's like
it'll keep you real because like you see
all these folks who've invested
their belief in you and like their
energy and they're like putting their
heart and soul into
into this work um and then it makes you
better because you're like well like
certainly if you're gonna invest that
then like at
the least i can do is like you know do
my part i
definitely think that my time with
hitrecord
and all the people that make up the
community
has made me a better artist
uh and also just like a a better person
that's better at connecting with other
people and
and collaborating and figuring out how
to do things together with with someone
who's got a different perspective than
you or
who comes from somewhere else or who has
an idea that's different than yours
um opening up that process uh i think
has
taught me a lot and then it's also
taught me a lot like you say about
about kind of what it means to try to
lead
which you know it when my brother and i
started hit record it was never
really the intention like okay we're
going to lead this huge thing but it
sort of
gradually evolved into something that's
that's now pretty big and um certainly
there are plenty of bigger things in the
world but like there's there's
all these people more people than i know
that uh that care about it and
care about each other and and it is it's
it i do feel a real
responsibility to that and and and
gratitude because it it it gives me a
really inspiring reason to
wake up every day that's beautiful man
it shows it shows in your work
and uh the other thing that i know
you're
experiencing alongside me is like being
a parent to two
young boys also like stretches you as a
person this is why i wake up
every day for sure being a dad is just
the best
the best yeah yeah i'm with you man
well all the best to you and your family
uh
and yeah i can't wait to see project
power it looks like a really fun movie
on netflix every time netflix delivers
us a new good movie it's like a gift
to everyone especially what's that like
there's
a movie to look forward to uh that the
tv series which i know we have a little
bit of a wait for
uh you know i think you're in another
movie that's out now too
um uh charles should there's three this
year yeah trial chicago seven's coming
out that's that's also on netflix
very different than project power uh
that'll take a whole other conversation
for us to talk about very very relevant
movie
oh it's fantastic well it's so good to
talk to you i'm really really glad
i'm just so happy to make friends with
you um i gotta thank kevin again
for introducing us and uh
and i hope we get to just stay in touch
man i love talking with you
thank you for listening in i hope you
enjoyed this conversation
if you did please do subscribe to yang
speaks and click on notifications so we
can let you know
every time we have a new episode
you